The Tales of Dunk and Egg is a prequel series
set 90 years before A Game of Thrones.
Dunk is a young knight – not a fancy noble
knight, but a humble travelling hedge knight.
He’s not very smart or skilled but he’s
tall and strong and determined to do what’s
right.
His squire is a boy called Egg, who is secretly
a Targaryen prince, and future king of Westeros.
In their first book, The Hedge Knight, Dunk
and Egg teamed up and fought a villainous
prince.
For the next couple years, Dunk and Egg travelled
around Westeros – they went down to Dorne,
fought some pirates, and visited Egg’s brother,
a young Maester Aemon, at Oldtown.
So now in the second book, The Sworn Sword,
Dunk and Egg are a bit older, and more experienced,
but they’ve still got a lot to learn.
The Sworn Sword was adapted to a graphic novel
with art by Mike S. Miller and Mike Crowell.
In the previous book, Westeros enjoyed peace
and prosperity in spring time.
But now, it’s a hot oppressive summer, and
Westeros is in “turmoil".
Cause the king, Daeron Targaryen, has died
in a plague.
And his beloved son and heir Baelor, tragically
died in the previous book, [partly because
of Dunk].
So now Daeron’s second son, Aerys, is king.
[Aerys the First, not the Mad King Aerys the
Second].
And Aerys is a weak ruler – he’s more
interested in dusty old books than in being
king.
So Aerys lets his uncle, Brynden Rivers, run
the kingdom.
Brynden, called Bloodraven, is a Targaryen
bastard with a reputation for sorcery and
spying.
He eventually becomes the three-eyed crow,
teaching magic to Bran Stark 90 years later.
But in The Sworn Sword, Bloodraven is Hand
of the King, ruling Westeros with an iron
fist.
When the plague hit King’s Landing, Bloodraven
had thousands of corpses piled up and burned
with wildfire, and the whole city glowed green
in the night.
Now there are ironborn raiding the coast,
and a terrible drought, and across the narrow
sea, Bloodraven’s half-brother Bittersteel
is plotting invasion with the Blackfyres,
after a failed rebellion fifteen years ago.
Meanwhile, Prince Maekar, the father of Aemon
and Egg, sulks in his castle at Summerhall.
So these are troubled times, and tensions
are high.
As a hedge knight, Dunk travels around Westeros,
working for whoever needs his sword.
So in The Sworn Sword, he and Egg serve a
knight called Eustace Osgrey, who has a bit
of land and a tower called Standfast.
Eustace is a sad old man, who lost his family
to war.
Fifteen years ago, Eustace and his sons fought
in the Blackfyre Rebellion, when Bittersteel
and Daemon Blackfyre tried to take the throne
from their half-brother King Daeron.
At the Battle of the Redgrass Field, Daemon
was killed in a rain of arrows from Bloodraven.
Bloodraven fought a duel with Bittersteel,
and lost one of his eyes.
Bittersteel and the surviving Blackfyres fled
from Westeros, to rebel again later.
Eustace’s sons died in this battle.
And his wife committed suicide [and his daughter
died in the plague].
Eustace says the death and carnage of the
battle was terrible – but he also describes
the beauty of the sunset over the Redgrass
Field.
Eustace copes with his grief and loss by focussing
on the glory of the war – the brave warriors
and heroic battles.
When he visits his family’s graves, Eustace
still toasts to the true king.
He also keeps relics of his family’s history
– hundreds of years ago, the Osgreys were
a powerful house in the Reach, and Eustace
treasures these old memories [of this glorious
past].
Dunk and Egg discover that Eustace’s stream,
the Chequy Water, has gone dry – [and they
need that water in the drought].
Because Eustace’s neighbour, Lady Rohanne
Webber, built a dam upsteam to take the water.
Eustace’s other knight, the mean-spirited
Ser Bennis, attacks one of Rohanne’s peasants
[escalating the conflict].
Eustace is furious that Rohanne took his water.
He says Rohanne is a cruel murderer with “a
spider’s heart”.
Known as the Red Widow, Rohanne is said to
be a witch who poisoned her four husbands.
Rohanne’s castle, Coldmoat, was originally
an Osgrey castle – you can still see a faint
Osgrey lion beneath the Webber banners.
Eustace won’t let the Red Widow take his
water, too.
He wants to show his strength and pride, and
prove “that the chequy lion still has claws”.
So he orders Dunk and Bennis to rally some
men and take back the stream.
They get some peasants from Eustace’s villages,
and train them to fight, and they’re…
pretty much useless.
Dunk and Egg realise that if these guys fight
the knights of Coldmoat, they’ll just die.
So instead, Dunk goes to talk with Rohanne,
to convince her to give back their water.
Dunk is a warrior who’s fought against knights
and pirates.
But he’s nervous about talking to the highborn
lady, Rohanne.
Dunk is just 19 years old [or 18], and he’s
awkward around women.
So Prince Egg tells Dunk how to wear some
nice clothes and speak properly to the lady.
At Coldmoat, Dunk meets Rohanne’s castellan,
Ser Lucas Inchfield.
He’s called the Longinch because he’s
tall – but not as tall as Dunk.
The Longinch is hostile and rude with Dunk.
He tricks Dunk into thinking that some random
other lady is Rohanne, just to fuck with him.
But when Dunk meets the real Rohanne, she’s
not what he expected.
She’s not an ugly old witch – she’s
a pretty young woman with a red braid and
freckles.
Dunk greets her awkwardly, but Rohanne’s
playful and witty, and they have some chemistry
– and she agrees to a meeting.
First, Dunk meets Septon Sefton, a drunk and
flatulent priest.
He learns that Rohanne didn’t murder her
husbands, they were just older men who died
of sickness, accident and war – two of them
died when Rohanne was a child.
And now, Rohanne must marry again.
Because according to her father’s will,
Rohanne only gets to keep Castle Coldmoat
if she’s married within the next month.
But she’s having trouble finding a good
husband – some men are put off by her reputation
for murder, and others are intimidated by
the Longinch, who is determined to marry her
himself.
Rohanne can’t get rid of the Longinch because
of her father’s will, and she fears he might
marry her by force.
There are also political rivals hoping to
take Rohanne’s land, watching for signs
of weakness.
Rohanne later says that as a young unmarried
female minor lord, she needs to show strength
to protect her power.
She knows this conflict with Eustace is a
meaningless pissing contest, but if she wants
to rule, she can’t back down.
So Rohanne demands that Eustace give her Bennis,
so she can punish him for hurting her peasant.
And she refuses to take down her dam, cause
she needs the water for her crops, and her
moat.
And besides, the water is legally hers.
Fifteen years ago, the king took the stream
from the Osgreys and gave it to House Webber.
Because in the Blackfyre Rebellion, Eustace
wasn’t a loyalist fighting for King Daeron
– Eustace fought for the rebel, Daemon Blackfyre.
Dunk discovers that the man he swore his sword
to is a traitor.
Dunk makes one more appeal to Rohanne by bringing
up Eustace’s dead son, Addam, who Rohanne
had loved as a child.
But it’s a sensitive topic – Rohanne blames
Eustace for Addam’s death in the rebellion
– so she gets angry, and slaps Dunk, and
threatens “Fire and sword”.
Dunk and Egg go back to Eustace and ask why
he joined the Blackfyre rebels.
He says that from his point of view, the Targaryens
were the traitors, and the Blackfyres were
the loyalists.
The Blackfyres believed that King Daeron was
an illegitimate bastard usurper.
They complained that he was weak, and that
he listened to women and Dornishmen.
But Daemon Blackfyre was a powerful warrior,
legitimised by his father King Aegon the Fourth
– and given the legendary sword Blackfyre,
the blade of the Conqueror.
Eustace fought for the side he believed in,
and he says they almost won.
If the Blackfyres had taken the Throne, they’d
be called the loyalists, and Daeron’s side
would be the traitors.
But since they lost, Eustace lives in defeat,
stripped of his lands and his family and his
pride, left with only memories.
Dunk feels betrayed that Eustace misled him
into thinking he was a loyalist, and saying
the stream was his.
So he decides to leave Eustace, but in the
night, Eustace’s forest called Wat’s Wood
burns.
It seems that Rohanne is carrying out her
threat of fire.
So Eustace and Bennis rally their peasant
militia and plan to fight Rohanne.
Dunk doesn’t want these innocent peasants
to be killed.
So he heroically sends the peasants home to
safety, and says he’ll end this conflict
himself.
Somehow.
Dunk and Egg and Eustace face off with Rohanne
and her men, with Rohanne wearing a super
cool spider-inspired outfit.
Rohanne and Eustace refuse to back down – Rohanne
wants to punish Bennis, Eustace accuses Rohanne
of burning his woods, which she denies.
The only way to end this with the lords’
pride intact is with blood.
So Rohanne demands a trial by combat – and
Dunk fights the Longinch.
The Longinch uses a two-handed poleaxe, and
both men are knocked into the stream.
They beat each other up pretty bad, but in
the water, Dunk kills the Longinch.
Dunk is badly injured, and he actually drowns
in the stream – luckily, Rohanne’s maester
is ironborn, and knows how to resuscitate
a drowned man.
And while Dunk recovers, Eustace and Rohanne
make peace.
They bond over their memories of Eustace’s
son Addam.
And Eustace and Rohanne get married – not
for love, but for political reasons.
Cause marrying Rohanne makes Eustace the Lord
of Coldmoat – he finally gets back his family’s
castle, restoring his Osgrey pride.
For Rohanne, marrying Eustace means she gets
to keep her lands, in accordance with her
father’s will.
And since Eustace is much older than her,
he’ll probably die soon – leaving her
to rule for herself.
So it’s a marriage of convenience that satisfies
both Rohanne and Eustace.
But Dunk is bitter.
It would’ve been nice if Rohanne and Eustace
made peace before Dunk nearly bloody died
for them.
And Rohanne never visited Dunk while he recovered.
Dunk and Rohanne had a thing going, they were
flirting, Dunk had crazy trippy sex dreams
about her and everything, but she goes off
and marries the old guy??
To apologise, Rohanne offers Dunk a beautiful
well-bred horse.
But Dunk says the horse is too good for him
– just like how Rohanne, as a highborn lady,
is too good to be with Dunk.
She insists on giving him something to remember
her by, so they share a passionate kiss, and
he takes a lock of her hair.
As Dunk and Egg ride north, a heavy rain falls
– welcome relief from this hot troubled
summer.
So The Sworn Sword is not a battle of good
and evil, it’s about two pretty likeable
characters whose pride and politics draw them
into conflict – with Dunk once again putting
his life on the line to protect the innocent.
And one of the recurring ideas in Dunk and
Egg is people not being who they seem.
Egg is not a peasant boy, he’s a Targaryen
prince.
Dunk isn’t technically a knight, cause he
was never knighted.
Eustace is not a Targaryen loyalist, he was
a Blackfyre rebel.
And Rohanne is not an evil old witch – she’s..
just a smart politician.
She uses her reputation as a murderous “Red
Widow” as a political tool to intimidate
her rivals and protect her power.
She’s not a monster – but she’s also
not innocent or naïve.
Damming the Chequy Water is a major dick move,
even if she legally owns it – cause without
the Water, Eustace’s villages’ crops will
die, for the sake of Rohanne’s moat and
her own crops.
And Rohanne did once drown one of Eustace’s
men for stealing sheep.
Rohanne can be ruthless… and cunning.
Cause this conflict works out really well
for her – she proves her strength by not
backing down.
She gets rid of the Longinch, who was a big
problem for her.
She gets a husband, so she’ll keep Coldmoat,
but Eustace is old so she’ll rule by herself
soon.
Everything goes so well for her that it’s
almost like she planned this.
Rohanne says she didn’t burn Wat’s Wood,
that it must have been a natural accident.
But it’s a pretty big coincidence that the
fire starts just after Rohanne threatened
“fire”.
She even kinda admits that one of her men
might’ve started the fire.
And the fire leads to this confrontation where
Rohanne demands the combat where the Longinch
dies.
One of the first things Rohanne asks Dunk
is “Are you as strong as you appear?”.
Maybe she planned to use Dunk to kill the
Longinch all along, and started the fire to
force this conflict.
Maybe this was all a trap, like the web of
the spider on her sigil.
Hell, maybe she did murder some of her husbands.
She says she didn’t love them, and it seems
she’d rather rule by herself.
We’re told that her third husband choked
on a chicken bone, and the fourth died in
the plague – but maybe she really did poison
them.
We.. can’t know for sure.
Rohanne is an ambiguous, layered character.
Like any lord, she risks the lives of ordinary
people for her power, and yet she’s still
a sympathetic character, making the best of
a difficult situation.
She illustrates the complex balance of power
and pride and moral compromise that you need
to survive in politics.
And Rohanne’s story continues.
The World of Ice and Fire history book reveals
that years later, Rohanne outlived Eustace,
and married again.
And her sixth husband was Gerold Lannister,
[who becomes] the Lord of Casterly Rock.
So Rohanne went from being a minor noble to
the wife of one of the richest and most powerful
lords in Westeros.
She had four sons with Gerold, including Tytos
Lannister – the father of Tywin Lannister,
who’s the father of Cersei Jaime and Tyrion.
So Rohanne is the great-grandmother of these
Lannisters – maybe they inherited her political
skill – except for Jaime – and for Cersei
she’s drunk [which is all of Book 4].
But after she had her fourth son, Rohanne
“vanished under mysterious circumstances”.
What happened?
Rohanne’s husband, Lord Gerold, is rumoured
to be a murderer – it’s said that he killed
his niece and brother so he could be Lord
of Casterly Rock.
But even if that’s true, those murders were
for ambition – why would Gerold murder his
own “beloved” wife, the mother of his
children?
[Probably married her for love in the first
place].
What was their relationship like, and what
really happened to Rohanne?
Maybe Dunk and Egg were involved.
Cause a few years after Rohanne disappeared,
Egg, all grown up, as a knight, fought in
a battle against some rebels.
And two of Rohanne’s sons fought alongside
him, one as Egg’s squire.
Egg’s father, King Maekar, died in that
battle.
And since his eldest kids and grandkids were
all either drunk or mad or nerds or Egg or
dead or female, a council was called to decide
who should be the next king.
And they chose Egg – he became King Aegon
Targaryen the Fifth.
And part of what convinced the council to
choose Egg was the words and the gold of Lord
Gerold Lannister.
Egg then chose Dunk to be Lord Commander of
his Kingsguard.
So clearly, Gerold and Rohanne and their family
were somehow involved in Dunk and Egg’s
later lives – it sounds like there’s a
story here.
Maybe we’ll find out in a future Dunk & Egg
book.
The author George Martin has talked about
writing ten or twelve Dunk & Egg novellas,
to tell their whole life stories.
So maybe one day, we’ll find out the fate
of the Red Widow.
Egg was an unusual king, because he cared
a lot about the common people.
He gave the peasants new rights and protections,
and sent food to the poor and hungry.
And you can see how this was influenced by
his adventures with Dunk in The Sworn Sword.
Like, at first, Egg acts too proud to work
with peasants.
But Dunk teaches Egg to respect the smallfolk
– they might not be as educated and noble
as a prince like him, but the smallfolk are
still people with their own pride and families
and skills, and they deserve Egg’s respect.
Egg also shows prejudice against bastards
– he heard that bastards are untrustworthy,
and “born to betrayal”.
But Dunk points out that Dunk is probably
a bastard – he grew up an orphan in Flea
Bottom, and his parents probably never married,
but that doesn’t make Dunk a bad person.
With Eustace and Rohanne, Egg gets to see
both sides of a political conflict.
Rohanne shows Egg that rulers are not always
what they seem – and a delicate balance
between image and power and pride are needed
to rule.
Eustace rebelled against Egg’s family, the
Targaryens.
But Egg learns why Eustace did what he did,
and sees that treason and loyalty, good guys
and bad guys, sometimes depend on your perspective.
Egg sees the long-term aftermath of the Blackfyre
rebellion, and the impact of Eustace and Rohanne’s
conflict on the common people.
It’s a great lesson for a young prince to
start thinking about how to be a good ruler.
His adventures with Dunk ultimately make him
a wiser and more compassionate king, unlike
his dysfunctional brothers who grew up in
luxury at King’s Landing or Summerhall.
And that’s why Dunk insists on taking Egg
on the road as a hedge knight.
Cause even the noblest proudest rulers should
have the humility and wisdom to stay grounded,
to respect the common man, and sometimes to
ride in the rain on an old horse.
After The Sworn Sword, Dunk & Egg’s next
adventure is The Mystery Knight – a story
of conspiracy, secret identities, dragon eggs,
and Bloodraven.
All three Dunk and Egg stories are collected
in A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms, read on
audiobook by Harry Lloyd, the actor who played
Viserys on Game of Thrones.
You can get this audiobook for free right
now by signing up for a trial with Audible
– choose the Premium Plus option for the
free audiobook.
Memberships now also include the Audible Plus
Catalogue, a library of thousands of audiobooks
and originals for unlimited streaming and
download.
As a special offer, you can get Audible Plus
for just $4.95 a month for your first 6 months.
You can listen while you ride in the rain,
or while you sleep beneath the stars.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching, please like comment and
subscribe.
Thanks to Mike S. Miller, the artist behind
the graphic novel, and thanks to the Patrons,
including Jeanine Clark, Andy Chen, Nina,
William, Braden Price, Trung Dong, Glen Thrasher,
and Alicia Leporati.
Cheers.